our favorite topic regular expressions I
already alright
regular expressions my secret love and I
want to talk next four minutes about
things I'm excited about so let's just
start with the regular expressions so
here we have a regular expression so
basically what this regular expression
says match a string that starts with
hello bums you are followed by dr. s
followed by a capture group that says
capture more than one character until
the end right so so far to go so when we
now call the exit method on this regular
expression what happens nothing we get
not because actually there is a question
mark and what we want to have is an
exclamation point right so when we do
this we get an error like result with
three things so what we do we get here
we have the overall matching string
we've got the first caption group and
we've got the second caption group so
what if I'm now I'm not really
interested in the first caption group or
do we do we can do we can use question
mark : and this is a non capturing group
in JavaScript expression not many people
are using that and with this you can
omit the first result which I think very
is very exciting but not a lot of people
are using this so a question mark : you
can omit caption groups and JavaScript
regular expressions so let's just go on
and change the second group to you to
this buddy so what do you say there's a
name capture group so what you can use
this question mark and angle brackets to
name your capture groups so what is the
result now of this area light result we
now have drift property which includes
the name of the group that you just had
so with this so you see there that we
have rest is matching to the group name
so you can use a question mark and angle
brackets and their name to actually
group your capture of groups that's a
really nice feature to have so when we
go now on and we add backslash one
because I don't know what that does that
is basically a Becht reference to
capture groups so when we execute that
we get a null because the word puncture
is not appearing twice and the matching
string so when we change this to Bonjour
Bonjour
basically it's matching again so with
backslash one you can back reference
character group so I think very nice for
complex regular expressions so
use backslash 1 and if I give any given
index with two back reference capture
groups so you might ask yourself now ok
Stefan but how do I do this for name
CAPTCHA groups right you can do the same
thing where backslash K and anger break
is in the name of the capture group
which means when I now execute this
regular expression what happens well we
got a null result again because we're
not having the same conduct twice
so when we change that to a how are you
and how are you you will see that it's
matching again so for name CAPTCHA
groups where they can do is you can use
backslash K and angle Rex and the name
of the capture group and with this you
can bec reference these which i think is
very exciting so when we go on let's
make this a little bit easier to read
again so we can actually view this and
it's matching him so we have this name
CAPTCHA group in there which has a
period right period is matching and
every character in a string but the
question is is it really so what happens
when I bring in a line break into the
string the thing is that the period in
JavaScript is not matching every
character it's not matching line breaks
so when you're not change that and add a
dot a an S flag which is the dot all
flag the period finally matches every
character so with this you got a
matching regular expression which is I
which is very cool my opinion so you can
use the dot all flags so the S flag to
make this period behavior actually
happen so when we have now this regular
expression and we go on how would we
check if their emoji is inside of this
string matching unicode emojis is not
the easiest thing in the world right so
what you can do is you can use backslash
P with the word emoji and with this we
got a non matching result because
there's no moji in there right but
working through now this and we can use
this kind of sequence of characters in a
regular expression to match emojis and
the same thing works for math symbols or
for language symbols so what you see
there are Unicode property escapes you
can use them with a piece slash and
curlies there are a lot of these out
there and I think that's very nice and
other features that I like but I haven't
at the time so let's look ahead and look
behind assertions if you don't know what
these are check these out
and we now have string prototype mesh
all which i think is very exciting
answering replacement ponens in it with
a dollar inside of this function and so
if you don't know these check these out
and thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]